You are Kendall Roy.
You are fucking Kendall Roy.
Is it true? He's on his way?
No, I don't see him yet...
with his stupid walk.
No drama. We're good.
-I'm gonna fucking kill him!
-(CLAMORING)
The revolution
will be televised!
♪ (INTENSE STRING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
He's our dad, but he was gonna
send me to jail.
He'd do the same
to all of us.
Shiv, are you okay?
Are you part of this family
or not?
SHIV ROY:
If I back you against Dad,
you would need
to let me take over.
Whoa, nelly!
GREG HIRSCH: Everyone's going
to battle in armor,
and I'm sitting here exposed.
TOM WAMBSGANS:
Logan is gonna fire
a million poisonous spiders
down your dickie.
That-- that sounds like
kinda dramatic, Tom.
KENDALL ROY:
Ask yourself, "Do you want
to be on the side of good
-or evil?"
-(YELLS)
You tell him I'm gonna grind
his fucking bones
to make my bread.
He says he's going to grind
your bones to make his bread.
(SCOFFS) Okay...
Tell him that I'm gonna run up
off the fucking beanstalk.
-(LOGAN ROY LAUGHS)
-He's kind of laughing
but not like nice laughing.